...
Salut ! Le résultat du premier tour est passé
pour les élections présidentielles, ça c'est fait.
Et c'est une bonne occasion, non pas de commenter les résultats
mais de parler de notre système de vote en France.
Système de vote qui ne va pas, qui déconne clairement.
Alors pourquoi il déconne ? Est-ce qu'il y a des autres solutions alternatives ?
J'ai creusé le sujet avec Hugo de la chaîne HugoDécrypte
et David de la chaîne ScienceEtonnante.
Et vous allez voir que quand on prend ça avec un esprit critique et scientifique,
le système des élections en France n'est pas si démocratique que ça.
...
En France, pour la plus grande des élections,
l'élection présidentielle, on vote en deux fois
pour notre candidat préféré.
Premier tour.
Et deuxième tour.
Au premier tour, il y a plein de candidats et au deuxième tour, il n'y en a que deux.
Il pourrait y en avoir trois dans une situation particulière
mais en général c'est que deux.
C'est un système uninominal :
on ne vote que pour une personne.
C'est pas toujours le cas, c'est pas toujours en deux tours :
il y a d'autres formes d’élections comme ça dans le monde.
Par exemple en Angleterre ils ne votent qu'en un seul tour. Donc c'est hyper violent.
Mais ça oblige les partis à se mettre d'accord en amont, avant les élections
et non pas après comme il est en train de se passer en ce moment.
Là c'est un cas en plus particulier
quand le Front National est dans la course
il y a une coalition naturelle qui se met toujours en place .
Mais peu importe, quand on regarde les dernières élections
après les partis font leur petit taf entre eux pour essayer de récupérer les voix des uns des autres.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les stratégies
c'est l'un des défauts majeurs du système actuel.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres défauts d'ailleurs ? C'est la question que j'ai posé à David
Bah les défauts du système actuel
bah on voit à chaque élection hein
c'est le côté couperet du passage du 1er au 2e tour
et qui fait que finalement les candidats qui vont être qualifiés
pour le 2e tour, des fois ça se joue à pas grand chose.
Et donc ça conduit principalement
à ce comportement qu'on appelle le vote stratégique
où du coup les électeurs
choisissent de ne pas voter selon leur conviction la plus profonde.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils choisissent de ne pas voter, parfois, pour le candidat
qu'ils préfèrent, celui qu'ils voudraient sincèrement voir élu
et ils choisissent de voter pour un candidat qui est mieux placé
et dans l'espoir d'éviter un candidat
qu'ils estiment encore pire au 2e tour.
Donc c'est le principe du vote utile
et on voit bien que le problème du vote utile
c'est que, il va naturellement pénaliser
des candidats qui ont été, au départ déclarés comme "petits"
c'est-à-dire que des candidats dont on estime
qu'ils n'ont pas trop de chances de gagner
et c'est notamment très orienté par les sondages
du coup se trouvent pénalisés par le vote utile.
Et donc les candidats qu'au départ on déclare petits
bah sont condamnés à rester petits.
En d'autres mots au lieu de voter pour un programme
on est déjà en train de voter
en imaginant le 2e tour
et en se protégeant plus ou moins
de ce qu'on aimerait voir ou pas au 2e tour.
C'est quand même dommage.
Mais ça on y reviendra.
Parce qu'il y a également d'autres problèmes:
le problème aussi c'est le vote blanc,
ce fameux vote blanc.
Il est plus facile de faire entendre sa voix
en n'allant pas voter. L'idéal d'ailleurs c'est d'être inscrit et de ne pas se présenter au bureau de vote
qu'en votant blanc. Parce que depuis quelques années on a admis que le vote blanc
existait, qu'il y a des gens qui votaient blanc, on a réécrit des trucs pour ca.
On peut trouver l'info de combien il y a eu de votes blancs, mais ils ne pesent pas du tout dans la balance.
On fait une élection au suffrage universel : il faut avoir plus de 50% des voix au 2e tour pour être élu
Aux élections précédentes, François Hollande avait eu 52% des votes
mais on avait pas pris en compte les votes blancs.
Si on avait pris en compte les votes blancs
donc l'intégralité des votes, votes blancs inclus,
faisant le 100%, alors il n'avait que 48% des votes.
En clair, il n'y avait pas de président élu au 2e tour
aux élections précédentes.
Si tu pouvais juste synthétiser ça, en quelques mots s'il te plaît... Salut Hugo.
Salut Fabien ! Alors en France, le vote blanc c'est assez particulier,
Et aujourd'hui, si tu votes blanc, ton vote devient... pas grand chose.
Tu as le droit de voter blanc en glissant une enveloppe sans bulletin
ou alors avec un bulletin mais sans nom dessus
mais en réalité c'est pas très utile. En effet,
si effectivement le nombre de votes blancs est annoncé aux résultat des élections,
(aujourd'hui on sait pour la présidentielle et pour le premier tour combien de personnes
ont voté blanc) pour autant, ils ne sont pas pris en compte.
Sur la présidentielle par exemple, aujourd'hui (2017) 100% des voix sont réparties entre les 11 candidats,
sans compter dans le pourcentage le vote blanc.
C'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle durant la campagne tu as pu entendre certains candidats militer
en faveur de la reconnaissance du vote blanc.
Reconnaissance du vote blanc, ca veut notamment dire par exemple
que si une majorité des électeurs votent blanc,
l'élection est annulée. Alors que donc, je me répète, mais c'est important,
si jamais on a une majorité des gens qui votent blanc en France,
c'est toujours le candidat qui a le plus de voix qui est élu président.
Et oui il a raison de dire que c'est important !
Si vraiment on était genre 80% de la population à aller aux urnes pour voter blanc,
ça n'aurait aucune incidence.
Donc quelqu'un qui ferait 50% des voix ne ferait en fait que 10% du vote global.
Ramené a des chiffres comme ca, on se rend compte que oui c'est un vrai argument de programme
de reconnaître aujourd'hui le vote blanc en France.
Mais revenons à nos petits candidats, enfin à ceux qu'on appelle les petits candidats.
C'est quand mémé terrible qu'on détermine comme ca
qui sont les petits et les grands candidats.
Je vous ai expliqué il y a quelques minutes mais vous l'avez compris
que nous-mêmes on est déjà stratégique dans notre manière de voter.
Simplement parce que notre système est mauvais.
Il est mauvais parce que tout notre raisonnement politique
on le donne d'une manière complètement erronée
en choisissant une seule personne sur un bulletin.
Et ca, ca ne peut pas traduire ce qu'on pense de chacun des candidats.
Je pense que vous, qui regardez cette vidéo, et que moi aussi,
on est plus nuancé que un seul choix.
Alors la vraie solution c'est que comme il y a 11 candidats, on devrait organiser 11 tours..
Mathématiquement, c'est ce qui tient le mieux la route.
Au premier tour, chacun vote pour l'un des 11 candidats,
on voit celui qui a eu le moins de votes parmi les 11,
on le retire du game
et on refait un tour d'élection en votant sur les 10 candidats restants, etc.
Et c'est une espèce de mort subite, à chaque fois, le dernier est éliminé
et on fait autant de tours qu'il y a de candidats.
Ce serait la meilleure alternative.
Le problème c'est qu'elle a un défaut majeur, évidemment
vous le sentez venir : c'est-à-dire que 11 semaines d'élections
c'est un peu compliqué, mais surtout faire bouger 11 fois les gens aux urnes ce serait
extrêmement compliqué.
En admettant que la personne se soit inscrite à l'avance,
puisqu'en France il faut s'inscrire avant le 31 décembre de l'année précédant les élections
pour pouvoir aller voter
et ça aussi je fais une parenthèse dessus mais je comprend bien que ce soit compliqué à mettre en place
mais aujourd'hui il faut changer ça.
C'est beaucoup trop tard.
Je pense qu'une majorité des gens au mois de décembre s'occupe de Noël
n'ont pas une vraie conscience politique à ce moment là
et à force de voir des débats à la télévision
ou de lire dans la presse ou d'en entendre parler
commencent à s'y remettre
à vouloir s'intéresser et veulent s'inscrire beaucoup trop tard.
Alors, je vous entends déjà à dire dans les commentaires :
"Oui, mais c'est un droit, c'est un devoir"
"on ne s'occupe pas de la politique quand ça nous arrange"
Peu importe !
Peu importe, en fait.
C'est juste important que tout le monde puisse aller voter.
Et c'est possible de le faire.
Dans le système Suisse par exemple
tout le monde est inscrit sur les listes, je crois.
Les Suisses, dites-moi si je me trompe,
Et il y a une obligation d'aller voter.
C'est une obligation.
Eh bien au moins, c'est réglé. C'est obligatoire.
Il n'y a pas à se poser la question "Est-ce que je vais voter ? pas voter ?"
"Est-ce que je me suis inscrit? pas inscrit ?"
Alors le système que je vous proposais, il n'est pas terrible sur 11 semaines,
mais il existe quand même d'autres alternatives.
Il y a le système Irlandais qui est intéressant.
Pour élire le président, en Irlande,
sur un bulletin,
on fait un classement de tous les candidats.
Ca s'appelle le vote alternatif.
Et ça simule, en fait, le nombre de tours dont je vous parlais.
Alors on se dit "Mais pourquoi  on n'utilise pas ça ?C'est juste formidable !"
Parce que, là aussi, il y a un problème.
Il y a un problème sur les 3-4 derniers.
Plus on monte, plus, mathématiquement, il y a des paradoxes qui peuvent se créer.
Dont le paradoxe d'Arrow qui fait qu'à un moment donné, dans une configuration particulière,
à 3, 4 ou 5 candidats
une personne peut s'auto-pénaliser en ayant trop de voix.
Si elle a trop de "bonnes voix" dans son classement,
C'est-à-dire en premier
alors elle peut laisser passer quelqu'un devant.
Pour bien comprendre ça, je vous invite à regarder une vidéo (que je vous mettrai en lien dans la description)
qui est faite par David, de ScienceEtonnante
C'est ce qui m'avait fait le contacter
puisque quand je faisais mes propres recherches
je suis, à un moment, tombé sur sa chaîne
et j'avais vu qu'il avait traité ce sujet l'année dernière, déjà.
Dans les autres systèmes qui existent aujourd'hui
il y a celui des Etats-Unis.
Alors j'ai demandé à Hugo s'il pouvait concrètement nous expliquer la différence entre les Etats-Unis et la France pour le vote.
Est-ce qu'il existe vraiment, d'ailleurs, une différence entre tous les pays, au final ?
Les différences, elles sont très nombreuses et entre tous les pays.
La principale différence, c'est que la France élit au suffrage universel direct
alors que les Etats-Unis élisent au suffrage universel indirect.
Aux Etats-Unis, c'est différent. A l'échelle des Etats fédérés, les électeurs vont élire des grands électeurs
qui vont eux-même ensuite élire le ou la présidente des Etats-Unis.
Et d'ailleurs c'est ce système indirect qui a permis l'élection de Donald Trump.
Près de 2 millions de personnes en plus, ont voté pour Hillary Clinton.
Mais c'est bien Trump qui a été élu président.
Comment l'expliquer ? Eh bien, son parti,
le parti républicain,  a réussi à obtenir une majorité des voix dans un certain nombre d'Etats importants,
où le nombre de grands électeurs en jeux était important.
Ces grands électeurs ont donc élu Trump dans la foulée, et il est devenu le président.
Voilà pour la différence principale entre les Etats-Unis et la France.
Mais ça peut être intéressant de voir 2 systèmes de vote alternatif.
On peut notamment en citer 2 que je trouve assez intéressants.
Le "jugement majoritaire" et le "vote préférentiel".
C'est ça. Ce que tu viens d'appeler le vote préférentiel, c'est ce que moi, j'appelle le vote alternatif.
Mais tu viens de parler du jugement majoritaire et c'est très intéressant.
C'est selon moi et selon la plupart des  gens qui travaillent un petit peu sur le raisonnement,
sur les mathématiques, sur tout ça,
le meilleur système de vote possible.
David a très longuement travaillé sur ce sujet également.
Est-ce que tu pourrais nous résumer le jugement majoritaire en quelques mots ?
Le principe de la méthode du jugement majoritaire
ce n'est plus de mettre un seul bulletin dans l'urne comme on a l'habitude avec notre système classique
avec un seul nom dessus.
Mais c'est de donner son opinion sur tous les candidats.
C'est-à-dire que tous les candidats, on va leur attribuer...alors on pourrait leur attribuer une note.
Mais, dans le système du jugement majoritaire, on choisit plutôt de leur attribuer une mention.
Donc il y a typiquement 7 mentions.
Donc ça va de "à rejeter" jusqu'à "Excellent".
Et puis, chaque électeur doit attribuer une mention à chacun des candidats.
Donc on donne son opinion sur vraiment tous les candidats.
Alors comment à partir de ça, ensuite, on détermine le vainqueur ?
Et bien pour chaque candidat, on regarde le pourcentage qu'il a obtenu dans chacune des mentions.
Et puis on regarde quelle est la mention que 50 % des gens seraient prêts à lui attribuer.
Donc c'est très simple. On trace un petit graphique comme ça.
On tire un trait à 50 % et cette mention-là, c'est la mention que 50 % des gens seraient prêts à attribuer à ce candidat
ou alors seraient prêts à lui attribuer mieux que ça.
Et c'est ce qu'on appelle la mention majoritaire du candidat.
Donc le système à la fin est très simple.
Chaque candidat reçoit une mention majoritaire.
Et c'est le candidat qui a la meilleure mention majoritaire qui est élu.
Et si jamais plusieurs candidats ont la même mention, on peut regarder les pourcentages
pour essayer de les départager.
L'avantage de ce système c'est qu'on se prononce indépendamment sur chaque candidat.
Donc il n'y a pas de notion de vote utile ou de phénomène d'interférence
parce qu'un petit candidat va venir gêner un gros.
Ou simplement, en fait, le concept de "petit candidat" n'existe plus.
Par exemple tous les candidats sont placés sur un pied d'égalité.
Et donc ça donne la possibilité aux électeurs de s'exprimer sur tous les candidats.
Et ça peut donc, potentiellement, permettre à des candidats, qui seraient considérés comme petits au départ,
de recueillir des mentions tout à fait correctes.
Et donc c'est une manière de corriger certains des problèmes du système actuel.
Bah une manière, ou la manière de corriger puisqu'on le voit, il n'y a plus de petit candidat.
Et là il n'y a pas un système de classement. Ca ressemble un petit peu au vote alternatif,
mais il n'y a aucun classement.
On doit nous, en notre âme et conscience, donner notre avis sur chacun des candidats.
Et ça, c'est très concret.
Parce qu'en plus ça nous oblige à nous intéresser complètement aux programmes.
Ca veut dire que tous les candidats réfléchiraient sûrement à leur programme plus tôt et le publieraient plus tôt.
Et nous, ça nous responsabilise aussi à le lire puisqu'on doit donner notre sentiment sur chacun.
Mais comme il n'y a pas de classement, on ne peut pas être stratégique,
en tout cas, pas complètement, puisque là, ça a assez peu d'incidence.
Au final, les 2 tours qu'on fait depuis des années dans cette Ve république font que,
au 1er tour, on choisit un candidat, concrètement,
et au 2e tour on élimine celui qu'on ne veut pas parmi les 2 restants.
Sauf si notre candidat fétiche reste.
Si on prend en compte le fait 1) qu'on s'oblige nous-mêmes à être stratégiques
pour ne pas voir certains candidats au 2e tour,
2) que le vote blanc n'est pas reconnu.
3) que les "petits candidats" gênent les "gros", malgré eux, évidemment,
mais, à ce moment-là, ils leur prennent des voix, en tout cas sur les qualifications,
4) qu'on rajoute également qu'on doive s'inscrire sur les listes
également 5 mois avant le début des élections,
Ca fait beaucoup de choses  qui prouvent que le système électoral en France est périmé.
Il est simplement périmé, enfin...
Ça c'est ma pensée, ça n'engage que moi.
Je vous invite dans les commentaires à me dire ce que vous pensez vous aussi,
en étant évidemment respectueux des avis de chacun, ça doit rester de l'ordre du débat d'idées,
et non pas de qui a la meilleure insulte.
Mais je crois sincèrement qu'on peut profondément réformer le système
pour qu'il soit réellement démocratique.
Et en même temps, réellement  responsabilisant pour les citoyens.
Voilà, ça me tenait à coeur de faire cette vidéo.
Je pense qu'il y a un lien direct avec le mentalisme, encore une fois,
puisqu'on a regardé avec un esprit critique en retournant un petit peu la situation dans tous les sens des élections
C'est aussi ça, s'intéresser aux choses et comprendre comment fonctionnent les choses.
Et exceptionnellement, pour ceux qui sont encore là, je vais vous dire de quoi va traiter la prochaine vidéo.
Eh bien la prochaine vidéo ce sera l'énigme pour le gagner.
Par contre je veux que la personne qui gagne ce trophée, le gagne vraiment,
ait un sentiment de "yes ! je l'ai mérité !"
Je ne vous dis pas quand elle sort, je ne vous dis pas à quelle heure elle sort.
Certains l'ont déjà déduits de toutes manières.
Comme toujours vous pouvez laisser un pouce et vous abonner
et rendez-vous très bientôt. Ciao !